a handful of protesters came out Friday
at Trump Tower in New York as news of
the former president's indictment
filtered through
about six kilometers to the South
outside the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office the anticipation among
the world's media is also building as a
date with history draws closer
but back in Florida Donald Trump's plane
remains firmly on the tarmac the man
himself staying behind closed doors
through most of the day
leaving his supporters to do most of the
talking for him I think these charges
are not legitimate charges I think what
is happening right now in our nation is
very sad and I feel that the direction
that we are headed is very dangerous
since the Manhattan District Attorney's
office confirmed Trump's indictment over
hush money payments to a former adult
film star speculation has amounted over
how Trump's arraignment will play out
they've got nothing and its potential
effect on the country Trump's lawyers
say they'll vigorously fight the charges
and framed the indictment as political
persecution it's believed Trump will
surrender on Tuesday and it's expected
he will arrive here at the District
Attorney's office where he will have his
photograph and fingerprints taken he
will then walk down a long hallway to
make his first court appearance at an
arraignment when he is free to leave the
big question then is is Will trump come
outside to address the media one person
apparently unwilling to be drawn into
the debate current U.S President Joe
Biden
the indictment I'm no comment on that
outside the District Attorney's Office
the wait is on now just days away from a
former president to show up and
surrender to face a judicial system that
is waiting for him
New York